i'm jennifer crumbly when james and
jennifer crumley appeared on a video
call to see their son in court on
wednesday they already knew they were
likely to face charges themselves
prosecutors say james crumley bought the
gun used by 15 year old ethan as a
christmas present his mother took him to
a gun range and laughed when he was
caught researching buying ammunition in
class
shortly before he opened fire teachers
found drawings on his desk depicting
scenes of a mass shooting his parents
were summoned but didn't take him home
reading this document looking at it
reading the words help me with a gun
blood everywhere this doesn't just have
impact me as a prosecutor and a lawyer
it impacts me as a mother
the notion
that a parent
could read those words and also know
that their son had access to a deadly
weapon
that they gave him
is unconscionable and i think it's
criminal the couple face a charge of
involuntary manslaughter for each of the
four teenagers who died that day
prosecutors say there's a mountain of
evidence that their son had been
planning the shooting for a long time
questions have also been raised about
whether the school should have done more
i believe mistakes were made at a number
of levels and
we're doing our best to you know make
sure that folks
that
were murdered on this tragic day get
justice
it's a measure of the nervousness in the
community that during a vigil for the
victims a panic broke out in the crowd
stay calm stay calm
stay
it calm out it was caused by someone
fainting
police say the crumblies will face
justice they'd even issued a warrant for
their arrest believing them to have gone
on the run it is highly unusual for the
parents of a suspect in a school
shooting to face charges like this but
as the prosecutor said america needs to
do better to prevent these tragedies in
her words enough is enough
greg milam sky news